الان الى العراق حيث افادت وكاله الانباء
العراقيه بمصرعي شخص واصابه العشرات في
صفوف المشجعين بسبب التدافع عند بوابات
ملعب جذع النخله في البصره جنوب العراق
وقد دعت وزاره الداخليه العراقيه
المواطنين ممن لا يحملون تذاكر مباراه
نهائي خليجي 25 الى عدم التوجه الى
المدينه الرياضيه في البصره معنا من بغداد
مراسل الجزيره سامر يوسف سامر ما الذي
يحصل
حادث تدافع ال سي الاعداد كبيره جدا هناك
في محيط ملعب جذع النخله الذي يحتضن
المباراه النهائيه في خليجي 25 المقام
هناك في البصره منذ السادس من الشهر
الجاري حادث التدافع نتيجه الاعداد
الكبيره التي تتواجد هناك منذ ليل يوم امس
وهناك اعداد ذهبت الى محيط ملعب المباراه
لمحاوله الدخول اليوم صباحا فتحت ابواب
الملعب ودخل من يمتلك بطاقه او تذكرت همم
المباراه وهناك اعداد كبيره تريد الدخول
ممن لا يمتلكون هذه التذاكر مما دفع
السلطات
العراقيه همم الى همم
الدعوه الى عدم التدافع وعدم التوجه اصلا
الى ملعب المباراه ممن لم يمتلكون هذه
التذاكر الانباء التي نقلتها وكاله
الانباء العراقيه عن وفاه شخص لم تؤكد حتى
هذه اللحظه
السلطات الرسميه بشكل رسمي ببيان او حتى
بتعليق وحتى وكاله الانباء العراقيه
نقلتها عن مصادر طبيه هناك ايضا حديث عن
وفاه شخص اخر ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يؤكده اي مصدر رسمي همم من هناك همم
الاعداد التي اصيبت بدات ب60 مصابا يقال
بانها ارتفعت بحسب بعض شهود العيان
المتواجدين هناك في محيط الملعب وتجاوزت
السبعين همم دعوات ايضا من قبل همم
الذين الضيوف تحديدا الاتحادات الضيوف همم
المتواجدين هناك في نصره لحضور هذه
البطوله الى دعم هذه البطوله وعدم التدافع
وعدم احداث هكذا حوادث رئيس الحكومه محمد
شيعه السوداني متواجد حاليا في البصره
يعقد هناك اجتماعات وصفها مكتبه بالعجله
للتنسيق والتحضير للمباراه النهائيه